moi à gauche à droite par ici par ICI
ICI bonjour ça va ça va bien et toi très
bien très bien très bien bienvenue merci
en je connais un peu c'est ce que j'ai
compr bah je connais pas du coup c'est
la premère fois je vi là ici mais du
coup j'allais dire bienvenue mais c'est
plus chez toi que chez moi B chez moi
j'aimerais bien mais pas vraiment quand
même bienvenue ah déjà je peux
t'interrompre à tout moment exactement
et là je je me tais et je passe à la
question suivante si tu fais ça tu
verras il y a pas de question piège il y
a pas de oh B tu peux hein je toujours
demander c'est quoi exactement une
question piège je sais pas ou alors
piège c'est c'est pour qui tu votes ou
avec qui tu dors quo c'est pas forcément
une question piège non c'est pas
forcément une question piège de pas
répondre quo je suis dans le piège je ne
peux plus sortir bonjour Virginie
bonjour Hugo merci beaucoup de d'avoir
accepté de venir ici c'est très sympa tu
le vois ici tu as cette petite cette
petite table oua avec pour l'instant pas
grand-chose mais dans quelques instants
du coup des des symboles qui vont
apparaître et tu as cette ce petit
buzzer très fonctionnel et normalement
quand tu vas appuyer dessus ça va
arrêter cette roue sur un premier
symbole d'accord est-ce que tu es prête
je crois bien queoui on peut y aller on
va voir du coup cette petite roue de
symbole alors c'est quoi C donc moment
il s'agit que j'appuie sinon on va
rester comme ça pendant des point
d'accord allez j'appuie ça s'arrête sur
la télévision mais pourquoi donc la
télévision là je pense tu vas avoir du
mal à le deviner celui-là c'est un
extrait d'une émission qui date de 2005
ok émission évidemment dans laquelle tu
apparais à l'époque tu étais animatrice
télé encore je te laisse voir le cet
extrait puis on en parle juste après
d'accord ok est-ce que ça c'est c'est
peut-être l'étape prochaine du de ta
carrière le cinéma bah le cinéma oui
mais pas à n'importe quel prix et
honnêtement qu'est-ce qu'on va proposer
à une animatrice blonde divertissement
de super intéressant tu aurais envie de
faire du cinéma dans faire ta du cinéma
quoi du cinéma du cinéma du vrai cinéma
du cinéma traditionnel oui j'adorais
faire ça oui mais j'adorais avoir un
rôle à défendre ouais rétarder tu penses
on est
ou qu'est-ce que ça te fait déjà de voir
ces images ça après quasiment 20 ans ça
18 ans déjà je suis contente d'avoir
changé de coiffeur ça c'est une chose
euh je R et non ce qui est marrant c'est
que je me souviens pas avoir osé dire
cette envie là parce que je je je
trouvais que l'image publique était
tellement loin de ça que quelque part
j'avais le sentiment moi que c'était
plus possible d'accéder à ce désir là
celui de jouer du cinéma parce qu'à
l'époque et peut-être toujours encore
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment très
compartimenté quoi être animatrice télé
ou c'est pas la même chose d'illeurs ça
ça demande pas quand même les mêmes les
mêmes capacités non plus après avoir
reçu le le César de Meilleure Actrice tu
disais j'ai passé des années à me
trouver naze et j'ai mis du temps à ne
plus avoir honte et honte de quoi du
coup honte de soi ça déjà honte de
soi toi tu as toujours une confiance
inouï en toi non non du tout bon voilà
je ve ça prend du temps quand même il
faut passer par les expériences faut
passer par par l'échec pour se rendre
compte qu'il est pas si grave mais
parfois on a même peur de bouger de peur
de cet échec là alors on met du temps à
se trouver valable quand même et
justement alors ta mère nous a
gentiment elle nous a gentiment ressorti
des des
archives un peu plus ancienne que que la
première qu'on a vu là on peut la voir
ici c'est une photo de toi sur cette
photo est-ce que la la Virginie qui a 8
ans sur cette photo elle rêvait déjà de
faire ce que tu fais aujourd'hui est-ce
que selon toi elle serait fière oh là là
là là euh alors si elle rêvait de oui
elle rêvais complètement de faire ça
j'ai j'aimais ça les cours de théâtre je
faisais des
stages et ça donnait quand même une idée
du collectif comme le sport peut le
donner faire quelque chose ensemble et
tu visisais je CIS d'ailleurs avec tes
frères et sœurs des des formes de de de
pièces de théâtre c'est ce qu'elle nous
disait oui je leur imposais mais ça
c'était mon côté dictatorial tu les
faisais même payer en plus enfin vous
les fais pay voà et très commerçant un
beau business dictatorial commerçante
enfin voilà un bonheur pour tout le
monde non mais franchement ça devait
être 50 centimes mon affaire ça valait
peut-être pas plus mais oui oui j'ai
imposé un peu à tout le monde de me
suivre dans des délires qui m'étaient
très très personnel quoi on va passer à
la question suivante ça te va bah ouais
ça me va relance la je va tout de suite
et elle s'arrête sur une carte on va pas
jouer à un jeu pas pour l'instant par
contre je vais t'amener des cartes et
pas des petites cartes elles sont assez
grandes tu vas voir tu vas les
reconnaître directement je te laisse les
je te laisse les découvrir c'est des
cartes et pas n'importe
lesquelles c'est cartes des des des des
des films que j'ai fait tu l'uras marqué
il y a 12 cartes ouais et c'est le
nombre de films que tu as joué en 3 ans
c'est pas mal alors regarde affiche
câlin oui affiche câlin mais ça mais
j'avais remarqué en c'est vrai affich
CIN affiche câlin c'est vrai est-ce que
c'est propre c'est français gen et ben
je ne sais pas moi il y a des il y a des
schémas c'est un câlin tout petit peu
plus sadique tu vois mais quand même
ouais pas mal de câlins quand même c'est
rigolo quoi c'est c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui présent mais 12 films
12 films et séries quand même parce que
là en l'occurrence il y a aussi une
série du coup bien avec qui sort sur
Disney plus en cette fin d'année comment
est-ce que tuexpliques cette
hyperactivité si on peut parler
d'hyperactivité je sais pas comment tu
le vois est-ce que tu le ressens comme
une hyperactivité d'ailleurs mais ça
paraî beaucoup comme ça non je le
ressens pas comme une hyperactivité je
fais le déni total de ce truc là moi ok
c'est chouette de tourner franchement
c'est super ouais oui c'est en fait du
coup tu forcément tuenchaînes et si on
sait en plus que c'était quelque chose
qui était là depuis longtemps tu du coup
une envie de se dire bah il faut que je
fasse FAI oui oui oui ouais par que la
vie est très courte quand même donc bon
justement on va voir dans quel film
aussi est-ce que tu tu pourrais jouer je
vais en fait afficher à l'écran des
affiches de films cultes pour chacun je
te laisse me dire si tu aurais aimé
jouer dans ce film ou pas d'accord ça te
va ouais le premier
[Rires]
bah évidemment qu' pas jouer dans P
fiction sublime film Palme d'Or est-ce
que j'aurais pu faire comme Yuma
thourman non en plus là on est vraiment
encore dans ces films là c'est quelle
année ça ça doit être 94 sia 90 hyper
libre chose qu'on fait plus beaucoup aux
États-Unis quand même les films sont
plus calibrés là il y a encore tu vois
il y a des trucs ça ça mélange plein
plein de choses que c'est ça en fait le
ouais il une affiche du coup qui est
resté resté culte on va voir la suivante
avatar ah non j'aurais pas du tout aimé
jouer enfin si en fait tout est rigolo
toute expérience est rigolo ah oui à
gauche effectiv ça il faut que je ça
pour ma fille ça va vraiment beaucoup
aimé alors oui bien sûr toute expérience
est super et tout mais tu dois quand
même gambader sur des fonds bleus
pendant des plombes c'est ce que
j'allais dire mais en fait c'est la
question pas sûr ça soit le truc c'est
sympa mais que tuas jamais fait des des
tournages avec ah mais tu as vu beaucoup
de films français avec des fonds verts
si il y avait un film d'Albert d Pontel
où il y avait pas mal de de Fonds vert
et tout mais pas des effets spéciaux
comme avatar ou passe la moié ah oui et
tu fais semblant tu dois jouer avec quel
chose et faire enfin tu
vois sympa mais je veux bien faire le
courtmétrage d'Avatar pour tester ouais
euh le suivant
ah Mariline mon Dieu moi ça c'est il y a
ma tronche là-dedans ouais ouais ouais
ah c'est rigolo le côté biopique alors
il me semble que tu es pas mal fan de de
mais le côté euh biopque c'est quelque
chose qui te plairait aussi que tu as
pas spécialement c'està-dire le côté
biopque souvent enfin moi ce que j'ai
envie de faire c'est des bons film mais
dans les biopics souvent il y a la
famille de la personne qu'on filme qui
doit valiser tout et de conj c'est assez
mauvais les les enfants qui regardent si
tout si on a bien dit qu'il était très
gentil tout le temps oui il était un peu
méchant là mais pas tant que ça le film
est ennuyeux quand même là je l'ai pas
vu ce film là et je pourrais pas jouer
mareline qui appartient évidemment trop
à un myth et puis pu puis c'est quoi tu
peux pas toucher à cette chos là mais
mais elle elle me fascine je connais
toutes ces chansons par cœur j'ai cru ce
que j'ai cru comprendre passer à la
suite d'accord mari story ah ouais ouais
grave ça j'aurais adoré faire à fond à
fond d'abord parce que j'aurais adoré
jouer avec Adam driver com pour moi
c'est un des meilleurs acteurs au monde
quoi tuas déjà rencontré ou jamais non
non jamais de toute façon si je
rencontre je serai pas enfin tu vois je
suis très nul pour tout ça et c'est
vraiment un film vraiment génial ça très
bien suivant euh ah c'est rigolo ce truc
bon pareil il y a les fond vert tout ça
et le laser oui c'est vrai je sais que
je ne seraiis jamais prise he pour ce
genre de chose c'estd ça peut arriver
qu' a besoin d'une francophone rô comme
ça tu besoin d'une bruxelloise dans Star
Wars le prochain et là ce sera une bonne
ser trs précis comm Mme une bruxelloise
dans dans cette scène précise on a fait
toutes les affiches je t'invite à
nouveau à appuyer sur la cette
roue ça va
s'arrêter sur un téléphone alors on n
pas ce genre de téléphone exactement
l'appel d'un ami quand j'ai annoncé que
tu allais tu allais venir et qu'on
allait échanger j'ai reçu pas mal de
questions différentes il y a une forme
de répondeur ici avec quelques questions
et je te laisse répondre rapidement à à
chacune des questions je ve pas les
rappeler les gens non t'inquiète
t'inquiète t'inquiète ok Virginie j'ai
vu à la dernière cérémonie des Césars
que tu avais introduit Brad pit avz
discuté avant ou après la cérémonie et
de quoi ah très rigolo alors euh oui oui
oui je devais remettre un prix enfin
proposé de remettre un prix à David
Fincher et puis on m'avait dit que
peut-être que Brad pit serait là j'ai
cru jusqu'à la fin que non en fait je me
suis dit p enfin il il va pas venir et
tout et le jour même on me dit que qu'il
est là donc formidable super et donc
j'attends à côté de la scène pour et
j'entends qu' a l'agitation que Brad
Pitt va arriver surtout je me mets un
peu loin genre pas j'en rien à fout de
Brad Pitt mais genre je me dis il y a
déjà tout le monde qui lui cour dessus
puisement qu' sait même pas enfin tu
vois qui va remettre le prix il s'en
fout je le comprends donc j'ai pas faire
hello Brad donc je reste un peu loin et
là franchement très bon endroit de de
frim je avec mon coiffeur qui l'a
entendu d'ailleurs qui était là
quiossait j'entends Virginie Virginie
énorme yes BR non non mais donc il est
arrivé en Virginie voilà et puis il me
parle je sais pas tout d'un coup
subitement j'avais un anglaet parfait
enfin je me suis imaginé ça ça peut
venir pour un Star Wars oui voilà c'est
ça et donc il me dit on va remettre le
Prix ensemble tout ça je dis bah
d'accord et en fait il me parlait je me
disais soit comme si j'étais au li
depuis 1 an soit comme si lui-même
habitait dans le même quartier de Paris
que moi quoi que c'était mon voisin à
côté de l'épicerie tu vois et donc ça
m'a enlevé le trac d'un coup d'un seul
et après il y a un grand dîner et là
j'étais placée à la table en face de
Brad P et David Fincher dû me parler du
film par que j'entendaisir par et je ne
comprenais pas ce qu'il disait avant
parce qu'il a quand même un accent ou
bien c'est moi qui V et donc je
faais donc c'était bon je suis pas sûr
qu'il s'est dit que j'avais un répondant
extraordinaire mais mais écoute il était
charmant et accessible pour tous tant
mieux tant mieux tant mieux alors la
suite coucou Virginie l'actualité est
assez anxogène en ce moment et je me
demandais comment ça va
toi mais écoute ça va et toi hein on
fait ce qu'on peut hein
euh bah comment ça va toi comment ça va
toi c'est pas sûr qu'il y a des grandes
périodes dans la vie même si euh mes
parents ont connu une période sans
guerre et tout ça mais qui a eu des
grandes périodes sans aucun
euh a dans paix éternelle la paix jamais
en fait éternelle remise en question en
permanence mais s'interroger sur comment
ne pas laisser certaines pensées
médiocres moches gagner du terrain
comment ne pas chacun se mettre dans un
clan ne pas défendre que son propre camp
d'abord c'est quoi un camp en plus B bon
bref allez voilà quoi tu vois ce que je
veux dire donc non ça va pas c'est la
merde c'est la merde c'est la merde je
CIS qu' reste Virgie alors pe-être un
peu indiscret mais comment ça se passe
pour les scènes de sexe est-ce que c'est
pas trop gênant non c'est assez chouette
en fait ouais non moi j'adore ça c'est
ce que je préfère
euh question qui doit revenir souvent
aussi parce que ah ouis ouai mais oui
mais c'est c'est marrant alors déjà ça
crée un truc dans l'équipe là là il y a
toute une équipe autour aussi mais quand
il y a ce genre de scène tout le monde
prend des positions un peu de Rodin quoi
comme le penseur comme ça genre les son
l' intime aux acteurs moi j'ai beaucoup
de fourir nerveux quand même donc je
toujours comme si j'étais à l'aise mais
en fait quand même je sens bien que je
rigole trop et que ce n'est pas normal
c'est stressant quand même il y a une
forme de ouais c'est stressant ça fait
peur ouais ça fait peur mais je suis
toujours arriver à à discuter avec les
acteurs avec qui je fais ça ou les
actrices et et on est vraiment ensemble
là-dedans et on cherche des choses et
c'est pas inintéressant hein voilà bon
très bien encore des trucs là attends ça
c'est quoi bonjour Virginie je me posa
une petite question est-ce que tu as
peur des punaises de lit ah voà des
questions non mais est-ce que mais alors
pas du tout pas du tout alors pas du
tout est-ce que tu crois que je
quelquesunes dans le et ben voilà je les
accueille et je les accueille je je
prends ça comme un cadeau ok jeis qu'
reste salut Virginie est-ce que tu
pourras raconter comment à 13 14 ans on
a réussi à voir le fil des agneaux ça
c'est ma copine Annabelle effectivement
et Annabelle c'est une de tes meilleurs
habisf c'est çaou ouais ouais ouais je
la connais depuis que j'ai 6 ans je
pense et donc je me rappelle plus du
tout comment on a fait je me rappelle en
revanche je sais pas si si tu as ça
aussi les souvenirs de sont comme des
flash donc je je vois la porte qui
s'ouvre et je vois que je regarde tu
sais en haut il y a la fiche avec écrit
et les séances peut-être même qu'il y
avait ce moins de 16 ans et comme si je
pénétrais dans un monde tellement
excitant quoi voilà et puis je me
rappelle du film qui était fou on va
passer à la question suivante d'accord
ça te va cette frou se relance et quand
tu le souhaites
ok un clap de cinéma je t'ai préparé un
petit quiz avec mon équipe d'accord ok
j'ai un beau sablier ici ok de 60
secondes et sur cet écran tu vas avoir
une succession de plans de films alors
c'est que des films cultes qui ont été
soit césarisé soit oscarisé l'idée c'est
qu'en 60 secondes tu arrives à en
repérer un maximum de filmsess je rien
savoir fa non non je pense que tu en
aurasas pas a des très faciles ok
d'accord tu es prête oui allez on y va
60 secondes est très facile euh Titanic
très bien euh ben du artiste oui adieu
les cons ouais ça aura été dommage que
tu Buges sur lui oui le parinès bien ça
c'est pas Amélie Poulin très bien
Gladiator les premers sont faciles très
bien on enchaîne euh la haines bien
pouro je fais ah merde ça c'est hyper
connu c'est oui c'est le Seigneur de des
anneaux des anneaux euh ça c'est
Benjamin voisin dans les illusions
perdues oui exactement ça c'est je
l'adore Fran c'est smackdorman dans elle
voit comment n's land oui oui oui le
truc ça c'est le film k C
Bou laisse-moi attends je vais le
trouver je vais le trouver dis-moi juste
le début la nuit la nuit du 12 par est
pas le plus facile par non je connais ça
c'est les chocolats non j'ai un trou
forest gum non mais ça va pas du tout tu
vois mais c'est la qui joue auss
qu'est-ce que c'est est-ce que tu l'as
il a un peu plus mais je penseonnais
rien attends je reconnais un peu ah si
je l'adore ce
film bien sûr 12
battement ça Discours d'un roi bon il en
reste quelquesuns mais très fort
continue tu t'en veux quelquess en plus
ouais ouais vas-y on continue rigolo euh
ça super film et c'est le film de
jacodiar et c'est le Prophète
exactement ça
c'est ah oui c'est le
filmien qui a eu qui a eu aussi oh merde
comment il
s'appelle je sais je vois très bien
c'est Sam dog
millionairedogonire tu vois je suis nul
bon tu t'en sors très bien franchement
tu en as eu tu en as eu énormément euh
mais il y avait quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est que là on a dit
c'est que des films oscarisés et
césarisés et ça ne t'aura pas échappé la
quasi totalité de ces films là ont été
réalisés par des hommes ouais de ton
côté ce qui est assez intéressant c'est
que depuis sur les h dernières années il
me semble près de la moitié de tes films
ont été réalisés si je dis pas de
bêtisse par par des femmes est-ce que
c'est un choix est-ce que ça s'est fait
naturellement alors c'est pas un choix
dans le sens c'estisé par un homme fa
belle merci beaucoup euh non ça peut pas
ça pe pas être ça l'argument mais c'est
pas tout à fait un hasard non plus il y
a beaucoup de femmes raisatrices en
France mais plus raatrices de films
d'auteur films d'auteur donc ça veut
dire film plus libre et avec moins
d'argent il y a pas beaucoup de gros
budgets qui sont donnés aux femmes et
donc peut-être dans cette possibilité de
plus libre il y a peut-être des choses
qui m'ont touché davantage et d'autres
types de récit quand même he d'autres
manières de voir et puis j'ai travaillé
beaucoup avec des raisatrices qui qui
projettent une forme de leur regard du
monde avec aussi
leur âge leur sexe et cetera qui cherch
peut-être quelqu'un pour interpréter qui
aurait plus ou moins c'est ces mêmes
caractéristique en l'occurrence moi donc
non c'est pas c'est pas comm hasard ça
s'est fait naturellement finalement par
le biais de de ça et d'ailleurs
là-dessus sur la question de la présence
en tant que réalisatrice ou actrice des
des des femmes au cinéma j'ai alors je
suis tombé sur des archives de Lina qui
datent de
1978 de Nadine trantigan qui s'exprime
dans l'émission cinégard sur France 3 OK
pendant des années bon c'était le cinéma
hollywoodien qui nous amené ça la femme
était mystérieuse la femme était vue
d'une façon très en même temps idéalisé
parce que magnifiquement belle et en
même temps pas du tout dans son
quotidien pas c'était une vision d'homme
peut-être une vision idéalisée pour le
spectateur une vision fausse aujourd'hui
pas seulement les femmes mais les hommes
aussi montrent les femmes autrement h tu
as sentiment qu'il y a un regard
différent des réalisatrices en général
non parce que ça voudrait dire qu'on
essentialise le regard féminin ou qu'on
essentialise le regard masculin et donc
on reviendra à quelque chose de pas du
tout féministe selon moi c'està dire
essentialiser la femme aurait un regard
il y aurait une manière d'être femme en
revanche il y a quand même des récits
différents c'est-à-dire le fait d'y être
arrivé plus tard de regarder une époque
différente je ne suis pas sûr que par
exemple j'ai fait un film avec Rebecca
zotovski qui s'appelle les enfants des
autres qui regardent l'endroit qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'être belle-mère l'endroit
de de enfin je suis pas sûre que ce
sujet là aurait abordé même manière ou
même aurait été abordé par un homme et
ce qui est juste dans ce que dit Nadine
trintigan là et qu'on peut voir aussi
aujourd'hui quand tu essaie de choisir
des films a une forme de responsabilité
qui raconterait quelque chose de femme
non pas forte mais au moins complexe
différente et tout ça ce regard là
n'appartient pas qu'aux femmes en fait
les hommes aussi peuvent avoir ce
regardl et il y a la question des
réalisatrices le regard des
réalisatrices il y a aussi la question
des actrices en tant que tell je suis
tombé sur cet article là qui date de
2019 un article dans térama les femmes
de plus de 50 ans ces grandes invisibles
du cinéma français ouais quand on parle
des femmes de plus de 50 ans ça
représente plus de la moitié des femmes
une femme sur deux en France aujourd'hui
mais c'est près de 7 % et après tu me
demandes pourquoi je fais beaucoup de
films il me reste plus que 4 ans mon
Dieu je vais tourner un film je te
laisse c'est ça le temps mais c'est
assez assez fascinant d'avoir ce ce cet
écart de entre la de représentation
finalement ouais ouais qu'est-ce que tu
ressens en vrai quand tu quand tu vois
ça est-ce que c'est des questions que tu
te poses ou pas du tout après çaagit à
la fois d'être lucide sur les choses et
en même temp de pas s'y assujétir non
plus pas se dire ah bah oui normal bon
ben dans 4 ans je je je vais aller
vieillir tranquillement à l'abri des des
des regards parce que plus personne
voudra de moi parce que plus que le
cinéma l'idée tout d'un coup 50 ans
arrivve bon ben merci écoute tout tout
ce qui d' sensuel s'il te plaît bah
réfugie-toi prends des gâteaux et ça ira
très bien pour toi euh non pardon mais
ça va être c'est pas trop comme ça que
j'envisage les choses donc moi je suis
peut-être dans un grand délire mais j'ai
pas l'impression
que moi je pense que je vais passer
audessus de cette chos là sauf si je
tiens ça il va falloir faire gaffe à
vouloir rester jeune h tu vois oui et ça
tu tu ressens une pression ou tu as tu
aurais peur de ressentir une pression de
euh je pense que il y a une pression
sociétale qui existe qui pèse sur T à
toi de te dégager je relance la roue et
quand tu veux
ok c'est un sablier bon encore un jeu
c'est encore un jeu c'est encore un jeu
un peu de vitesse mais en l'occurrence
là j'ai envie dire il y a pas de bonne
et de mauvaise réponse parce que c'est
tes réponses à toi ok je vais te poser
un maximum de questions il faut répondre
sans réfléchir al si tuar à réfléchir
c'est fa
répondre faut répondre par oui ou par
par un maximum de questions et s'il y en
a où tu ça te semble impossible tu dis
passe et je passe à la passe sucord très
bien est-ce que tu as déjà pleuré devant
Bambi oui il est sympa bras pit oui tu
as déjà triché lors d'un examen oui
est-ce que un film de 3h30 c'est trop
long un peu tu es optimiste pour
l'avenir de la
planète c'est rien à je sens c'est plus
tu regardes tes propres films à la
télé non l'argent fait-il le bon
non les salles de cinéma est-ce que ça
va disparaître un jour non est-ce que tu
as le sentiment d'avoir réalisé tes
rêves oui jouer une grande méchante
est-ce que ça te tenterait oui est-ce
que Paris c'est mieux que Bruxelles non
est-ce que c'est difficile d'aimer les
enfants des
autres si tu peux répondre que oui ou
non tu peux mettre un je pass sur
celleci non allez voilà je veux dire non
alors très bien est-ce que ça t'arrive
encore de passer des castings je
pourrais mais non est-ce que les gens
son dorme vraiment au César oui tu te
vois faire du cinéma toute ta vie à
partir de maintenant oui est-ce que tu
pourrais jouer un rôle intégralement en
anglais
oui of
course en je je m'arrêterai làdus c'est
parfait je dis il y a des questions que
vous sa c'est très dur de répondre parou
par non vas-y je t'invite à appuyer à
nouveau sur le
buzzer et ça s'arrête quel contrat
vas-tu me faire signigner écoute s'il
est là c'est ton prochain film en
l'occurrence il y a quatre affirmations
qui vont s'afficher à l'écran ouais sur
ces quatre il y en a une qui est fausse
les autres sont vraies d'accord SV je te
propose de les lire les unes après les
autres essayie de deviner laquelle est
fausse et laquelle est vraie Bambi a
étaé montré une fois par mois en prison
un braconnier parasite a convaincu la
ville de solou a versé une aide à plus
de 1000 foyers modestes les
suivant gravity a poussé la NASA à
appliquer de nouvelles règles de
sécurité dans
l'ISSS et le dernier les d de la mer à
faut augmenter la pêche au requin aux
États-Unis alors je vais te dire ça je
suis sûr que c'est vrai ça je pense que
c'est vrai
aussi faux le premier faux pour Bambi
Bambi c'est faux ouais en l'occurrence
le faux c'est gravity ah gravity n'a pas
poussé la NASA à appliquer de nouvelles
règles dans l'ISS ben il pourrait y
avoir des choses absurdes comme ça je
sais pas tout d'un coup tu nait pas
pensé à ça et donc Albert pour la fusée
là ça mais par contre ce qui fou c'est
que bon celui-ci est faux mais tous les
autres sont vrais ouais est-ce que
pourtant un bon film c'est un film qui
laisse une empreinte justement sur sur
la société non enfin oui et non qu'
laisse une empreinte sur la société là
on parle de là là c'est carrément ça a
aidé socialement machin ça fait monter
quelque chose ou c'est comme quand je
sais pas je je pensais au livre de
Camille couchner tout d'un coup sur
l'inceste et tout d'un coup après son
livre il y a un changement de loi et
Machin s'il faut tout ça pour que c'est'
y a un bon livre alors il y a peu de bon
livrees
ouose que tu conis pas un ça toérance ça
a grandi ton monde en fait c'est comme
la littérature tu accès tout d'un coup à
la pensée de quelqu'un mais un film tu
dis ok wou j'ai pas je vois les choses
autrement et du coup si tu l'as en toi
tu peux le transmettre à quelqu'un
d'autre donc oui je crois que ça change
quel chose toi d'ailleurs en tant
qu'actrice ça te par que là on parle
d'une empreinte sur la société mais
est-ce que il y a des rôles qui laissent
une empreinte sur toi et qui te change
euh oui mais tu arrives pas bien à
savoir quoi exactement et quand en fait
il faut il faut avoir un peu de faut que
du temps passe pour te rendre compte
qu'il y a quelque chose là qui s'est
produit que c'est rare d'avoir des
métiers en fait tu te mets dans la peau
de d'une autre situation qui n'est pas
ton quotidien et je vois pas j'en ai pas
d'autes en tête quoi final oui tu
t'aventures dans quelque chose tuavis
pas forcément prévu initialement dans
ton parcours de exactement puis ça
t'aide à ressentir d'autres choses sans
forcément les intellectualiser c'est par
l'expérience du corps qu' a quelque
chose qui se en place et tu te rendes
compte que tu peux que cet étatl il peut
faire partie de toi enfin ouais c'est
quand même c'est quand même intéressant
trèsès bien c'est un métier très
psychanalytique je trouve on va passer
justement à la dernière dernière
séquence je t'invite une dernière fois
je t'invite à appuyer sur la sur cette
roue sur ce buzzer plutôt
d'ailleurs c'est un symbole baguette
magique alors on va pas parler de de
Harry Potter mais on va parler de magie
de magie du cinéma plus largement en
fait on va faire venir à la place de
cette de cet écran des objets de trucage
qui sont utilisés au cinéma ah d'accord
donc là c'est des éléments de alors
peut-être qu' faut juste retirer le
verre comme ça on va ouais c'est bon ok
est-ce que déjà tu peux deviner ou ou
reconnaître certains là évidemment c'est
des cicatrices toi tu tu as joué des
rôles quand même où tu as eu des
cicatrices benedeta not ou j'ai fait
plusieurs benedeta là j'avais cicatrice
j'avais les scarifications avec tout un
système où le S cou poul et tout ça et
j'ai fait aussi un film où je jouis une
femme de 80 ouais 85 ans et tout ça et
du coup il y avait un maquillage qui
dure euh vraiment beaucoup de temps
parce qu'on place cette chos là enfin
pour pour changer tout et ça ça prend 4
5 heur de maquillage un petit temps de
ah ouais c'est infiniment long je crois
que tout j'ai puisé tous les
podcasts possible et imaginable euh on
est très doué en France he pour faire ça
ouais ouais franchement c'est assez ass
impression ça ben ça c'est la cantine
c'est la
celui dans ce préci en plus l'urence
comme ça vraiment env ah c'est bien je
me disais bien tu vois la qutine
heureusement que tu l'as pas goûté ou
qu' a pas eu jamais dû faire semblant de
vomir enfin si les bruit mais jamais
avec un petit truc comme ça c'est sympa
en tout cas ça c'est du sang je crois ah
ça c'est du sang je sais même pas d's si
c'est le je crois que ça a certains tu
peux les
non non c'était pas celui-là
heureusement que tuas pas fait pareil
remque paselulass c'est du S ça c'est du
sang ça c'est quoi ça ça alors est pas
si tu as déjà eu alors fais attention
c'est du ENF fais attention non non
c'est du mentol si je dis pas de bêtises
ah pour faire pour pleurer non je
t'avoue que ça c'est un truc que
j'arrive à faire sans rien du tout tu
enas pas besoin tu fais ah non pas du
tout OK ou mais comment tu fais du coup
tu te non c'est avant comme une imbécile
je metais dépensé des trucs et cetera
après j'ai trouvé un bon système ça être
dans la scène et voir si les choses
arrivent ou pas et après il suffit en
fait que tu actionnes quelque chose qui
qui est presque à l'intérieur qui est de
l'ORD de la respiration qui a un truc et
la fille qui veut vraiment jouer devant
toi et tu as le truc oui oui non
oui ou ou
ou chant de sujet parce que parlons des
vrais sujets par que l'émotion qu'est-ce
que un C les les aux
yeux non ça c'est extraordinaire ça
c'est chouette de montrer les truc comme
ça parce que les G les G savent pas
forcément heureusement pour eux
d'ailleurs donc
ça on va montrer sur toi non donc ça ben
justement s'il y a une scène de de de
coit bah il il y a quand même la pudeur
et puis puis si jamais il faut se
toucher de ça bref donc benah voilà on
applique ça et du coup ça veut dire que
ça on a quand même de l'autre côté ouais
et alors c'est c'est un grand sens
esthétique déjà c'est vraiment chouette
dépl ave ça vraiment super ça m'a pas
tellement manqué de travaill travailler
de pas travailler pendant un an
j'imagine qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre
rapidement ça c'est du faux alcool
j'imagine oui c'est faux alcool c'est je
trouve ça chiant parfois parce que tu
joues des scènes
par exemple tu joues l'ivresse et quand
tu bois il y a il y a un pauvre goût de
de de de Seven up c'est c'est emmerdant
une pe déception quoi sur le oui parce
que quand tu joues tu crois enfin tu
essayes de croire en ce que tu fais et
là il y a ça ça te ramène au réel tout
le temps quoi ça c'est quoi ça ça c'est
des faux biscuits je pense pour défut je
que les gisateurs prennent pas de poids
vrai ah non tu as raison j'avais hyper
faim en fait c'est quand même le
principe de la séquence c'est quo c'est
vrai non ça c'est ça c'est des vrai et
ça c'est du vrai et ça alors ça j'ai
j'ai pas osé le c'est c'est trucs qui
peuvent se casser ouais c'est génial
alors j'ai pas osé le tu veux qu'on
essaye tu pe en vrai si tu peux Esser
même sur ma tête he je pense le truc non
non j'ose pas tuose pas bah non regarde
là je faire bah là là
là waouh ah merde merde on va devoir
ranger on va devoir tout nettoyer mais
tuas vu c'est bien c'est incroyable en
plus c'est léger ouais ouais
ou voilà ah oui c'est très léger ah ouis
il faut vraiment am avec précaution
c'est une belle fin d'interview ah ouais
c'est
super du sang et du et du mentol pour
pleurer merci beaucoup merci à toi à
bientôt toi tu as terminé avec tes mains
sang et tout avec les mains comme il
faut B c'était super bah oui très bien
pour toi ça ça va ou trop bien c'est
rare de finir une interview avec des
mains en S c'est quand même
unuc whis j'aiim que tu avais étranglé
quelqu'un juste avant au revoir merci au
revoir merci
[Musique]
beaucoup